this episode I mean first of all our
guest is Joe DeRosa we had that already
already and then popping the great Ari
shaffir came in with his dog banned it
we started talking about philosophy we
started we started talking about Joe's
neck pain we started talking about a
whole bunch of things it was no it was
all over the place we actually uh yeah
we talked about we played a guessing
game at the end which is awesome
and it was awesome no dude well who
cares you'll bleep it out oh yeah guess
who the actor is for performing uh
shooting a movie on Arch Fierce block we
bleeped it out and guess what else if
you go to chrisdcomedy.com August 17th
to the 20th I'm at the brain improv
September 8th to the 10th Cobb San
Francisco and September 30th the Chicago
theater
chrisdcomedy.com and here's the thing
guys right now this second on sale for
me at 13 new cities uh Hamilton Ontario
Toronto my first time in Canada you ever
been I heard it's lovely Richmond
Virginia Hershey Pennsylvania Knoxville
Atlanta Birmingham Jack Jacksonville
Tampa Orlando Sacramento San Jose and
Santa Rosa have all been announced
yesterday they're on pre-sale right now
with promo code God bless and tomorrow
on Friday they go on sale to the general
public so this is the chance for you to
get all the good seats in those cities
right this second you've been asking me
they're out there don't tell I didn't
tell you do not say I didn't tell you
there you go all right here let's do the
one for Santino now quick right
babe Andrew Santino was the guest the
great red rocket the the one half of the
bad Friends Podcast you know I'm from
Dave you know from his podcast whiskey
Ginger fantastic episode we talked about
all types of stuff we talked about a
little bit of History Santino came in
and told us wild stories about Hawaii
playing freaking golf with Patrick
Mahomes yeah that's crazy nuts shark
diving shark diving it was wild talked
about the Mega Bus and he's got red hair
so you watch this episode it's good luck
christycomedy.com for Tiki wikis I will
be in the brain improv August 17th to
the 20th San Francisco September 8th to
the 10th Chicago Theater September 30th
christycomedy.com more dates probably
being added on sale right now Hamilton
Ontario Toronto Richmond Hershey
Knoxville Atlanta Birmingham
Jacksonville Tampa Orlando Sacramento
San Jose and Santa Rosa all announced
last week all on sale right now at
savocano comedy.com
[Music]
hey babe now tell me it's gonna be you
and me forever
where am I caught in a hit and run
everybody everybody hey baby everybody
in the club getting tips here do you
know my friend used to think that that
they were saying I swear like everybody
in the club's getting tits
which is really a better song really do
you know like that song by Bobby Brown
everybody's humping I heard it I heard
it yesterday yeah my mom heard it
yesterday I remember we used to my mom
used to blast that song because she
thought he was saying everybody's
pumping the jams and social yeah it
doesn't even sound like I know she go
that should go every and then one time
we're blasting in the car and my aunt
goes Lynn you know they're saying
everybody's humping around right and
then and then she was like no they're
saying everybody's pumping the jams and
she was like no they're saying
everybody's humping around and she's
like turn that off and I was like I love
that song we should do the whole episode
and never acknowledge that Joe DeRose is
here
you should have join it on the song I
didn't know I was supposed to
I thought I thought you guys did the
song and then as the guest you
introduced me I thought when I co-host I
had to do the song oh okay yeah I didn't
know no matter what happens we love you
yeah yeah like like our guests don't do
the chances okay you know that's how I
thought of it was but good to be here a
little uh you know you know what you
little and and like the kids in the
neighborhood are talking about and oh do
you know what this means do you know
what that means yeah like like you know
like I remember in uh I think I told
this story before I remember in fourth
grade uh this girl told the kid in our
class she got pissed off at him and
she's like you better stop or I will
give you a [ __ ] right did you ever
tell you that no no no no but I know and
then like the teacher was her name was
Miss karahi she was like a little little
shout out Miss Carter here she's she was
I'm not joking she was four foot six she
wore like a movie that little person no
she was like a little like a little
Butterball of a lady but I mean what
counts as little person Pimp's gonna
pull that up Let everyone take again she
was under five feet my count my guess is
you are you are you are a diagnosed
little person I would say under four
feet what's your guess I think it's 4-1
is to cut off what do you got
yeah I'd say under four six what's the
answer pimp 410 or less four whoa she
might have been a little bit wow so
Danny DeVito just makes the cut because
he's like 411 I think that's what they
say no way Danny DeVito is 411 there's
no way he's probably like five two but
I've met him he's tiny he's not 411 Joe
he's not three or four eleven four ten
he's a dwarf he's not no he's not he's
not a literal dwarf 410 and under his
dwarf that's what it really yeah yeah
but he's not he doesn't but is he
considered that though 410 and under
store no I don't think it's 410 under
his dwarfism per se I think it's just
what it says on online here well then it
must be true there's 410 or under
and you can't say [ __ ] anymore
it's been like 10 years really not in
Staten Island in fact it's been like
they did a Seinfeld about it never okay
don't you think little person sounds
worse
yeah a tell had that great joke about it
did he he was like he's like he's like
there's a lot of arguing he's like some
people he's like you're not supposed to
say [ __ ] and he's like some people say
you're supposed to say dwarf other
people say little person you know what
they actually want to be called people
[Laughter]
sure some of the kids in the class maybe
knew what it was but some acted like
they knew it was bad but no one really
knew yeah and then she and then and I
was like oh my God I kind of knew it was
bad right but she goes she literally
said to this Dad I can't believe it but
she goes ah she got flush and she goes
don't say that and she goes why she goes
I'll I'll get my [ __ ] right now it
was fourth grade she didn't know she
said can you go outside she told me can
you step outside the classroom and tell
her that that's not like tell she I now
that I'm thinking I'm blowing my own
mind she said tell her what that is
what did she think it was a wedgie
interesting yeah how do you get a
[ __ ] from into a wedgie who the hell
knows the wind blowing your shorts and
she said I know what it's like it's like
a wedgie and then I was like it's not
that but I didn't really know what it
meant but I can't believe this woman
told me to tell her what it is but my
point was you know when you're little
and you don't know and people like you
ever heard of this you know what this is
I remember when we were little uh in the
neighborhood one kid was like oh you
know hump you know what a hump to hump
somebody is and humping I guess is just
around humping around yeah but the kid
was like it's when you do it in the in
the butt humping they call it humping
when it's in the butt and I was like we
all everyone believed that but I don't
think that's I didn't know I didn't know
until I was steadfastly approaching 40.
that knock in the boots meant like meant
like the her boots knocked together yeah
I thought it meant like the booty like
I'm knocking the booty no I thought it
was like you're knocking boots like your
boots and her boots are hitting together
well yes but I didn't know it literally
meant boots I thought it meant like
booty right like I'm banging the booty
and the I'm knocking the booty well like
you thought boots was a shortened
version of Booty like that's what I
thought that's actually a fun name for a
butt it is hey look what a nice yo you
see her boots I can't believe it's
literal boots yeah yeah
well because because it's an old school
term but boots you're right boots is
actually better than booty it says fun
yeah but who's who are you having sex
with what woman you're having sex with
that still has her boots on is another
interesting it's actually like it almost
sounds like a Swedish way to pronounce
but but but I got it in my boot but I
have a I have a friend
who's I who I believe is latently you
don't have a friend ah stop it who is it
and also we know you didn't hurt your
back from sleeping wrong you told me
what big activities you did
why did you tell me it was no I slept
bad are we supposed to call me a pig I'm
sure it wasn't from knocking butts
I I took a picture of it I just saw a
Tea Company and the name of the Tea
Company is T pigs and I just thought it
was enough to be in Georgia The Sandwich
Board came in then I ordered that as the
pigs carrying the tray yeah
I'm bringing it into here by the way
we're doing a hey babe live from Joey
Rose's uh sandwich shop on Rivington
Street Manhattan check it out please
come down Tuesday through Sunday
joeyro's nyc.com so anyway
um
I have a friend who's I believe very
much is latently homosexual okay and
blatantly blatantly what does blatantly
mean like he like he's in the closet
like or he's in denial he won't come out
about it to himself or to us you just
talk about me out to my face yeah yeah
but he when he talks about
sex
there's an element of it that's similar
to what you're talking about and I've
made fun of him
to other friends before where I go he
sounds like when a 12 year old brags
about sex but remember that when you
were kids yeah and the kid would be like
dude her I fingered so and so her vagina
got so hot you know what I mean like
would say things that weren't that
wasn't how it worked and you'd be like
wait what what you know like he talks
like that where I'm like this is like
there's something just kidding sounds
like a 12 year old kid on a playground
he doesn't know what he's talking about
the scene from 40 Old Virgin is one of
the best when he's you know like that
scene in 40 old version when Steve
Carell's trying to explain sex to like
Seth Rogue and the other guys and he's
like yeah boobs they felt like bags of
sand yeah they're like wait wait wait
wait wait is that right
he doesn't know on the show we had Merle
one time just like I forget the context
but he kept going you want to do it like
let's do it doing it it's so funny I
know like the 80s they were like yeah
they did it they did what do you think
the worst term for sex is because I have
mine hands down that gives me the
heebie-jeebies but you go sex I would
say the worst I mean I bumping uglies uh
like Oh you mean something like that I
think the worst I think the most um
hideous term for a vagina I would say is
between [ __ ] and [ __ ] I would say those
are brutal those are rough but I just
mean for the act of sex
uh the worst I would say um I mean you
know doing the Hokey Pokey is stupid
um is that a thing yeah doing the whole
community no I know the horizontal poker
no horizontal oh the Hokey Pokey no
that's a dance your term at the
horizontal Mambo
yeah
what have you ever heard Hokey Pokey for
sex I've never heard that no you're
doing um um the horizontal what about
the vertical it could be a vertical
depends mine is listen my skin crawls
it's only ever said in movies as far as
I know my skin crawls when somebody goes
uh do you do you like our love making
it makes me sick make love is so gross
dude I almost never am in the mood like
I don't know if I've ever made love with
anyone because every time I'm having sex
with women I'm just looking at my body
and I'm just angry at myself so is she
you ever you ever hooking up with a girl
and then you take your shirt off and she
asks you to put it back on uh turn the
lights off I've never had that happen
but I've had plenty of times happen
where like she's totally naked and
she'll take she'll like get your clothes
off just take my pants off she leaves
her short on
that [ __ ] like Winnie the Pooh yeah
yeah like and I'm like I get it yeah I
get it I noticed I noticed I noticed
most women I have sex with they'll start
like you know she'll be riding me and
then always wind up reverse cowgirl
because she doesn't want to look at my
tits so she just turns around she'd
rather look at my feet but is yours
actually I've seen your feet she
probably turns back around she's like
this guy's yeah she's right yeah she's
like I gotta sit sideways on this guy
it's Horror in every direction
I know I don't I guess my hair is the
only women women always say the same
thing or I've always had throughout my
life it's it's always a letdown when I
take even when I was in shape
no because the thing is though is I
think I'd rather be I'd rather be just a
no doubt about it fatty right then uh
then a woman be like oh I bet you he's
jacked under there at least they know
you know I'd rather just have a body
where they know but you're jacked not
enclosed but not when I take my shirt
off it's it's bad jacked and closed
that's a great special name Jackson
closed the name what would you even do
with the perfect body with the perfect
body how do you change your life no I
think well first of all I think that's
why we've all become comedians is
because we all have major uh
imperfections that I think if it's got
the perfect body they wouldn't we could
have maybe become actors actresses
politicians yeah but not comedians but
they're not funny no no we develop our
sense of humor because I always had to
have something because I had a fat left
hit so he said to have a comeback what
comic is like shredded and funny
shredded and funny recipe was in great
shape and he was hilarious okay yes and
he's he's Fair very funny I mean very
good looking he was one of the only guys
I could ever think of Dane Dane was in
good shape and funny
what was it known as she was on the head
cover of Men's Health
when he was doing all this like Jessica
Alba movies he was [ __ ] ripped Kevin
Hart was jacked yeah yeah oh yeah that's
true yeah buddy yeah you know I have a
new Theory though I was a billionaire
I'd be jacked I have a new Dairy you
think so yes I do you think you had a
billion dollars you'd be jacked no oh I
wish they were like you could pay a
billion dollars and we'll do something
to your body unless they could
surgically remove my head and keep me
alive and put on somebody yeah
Friday with somebody no dude I'll never
be not lazy I'll never more money will
bring more laziness I'll buy more toys
I'll buy more things to distract myself
I will never I will never spend my time
like jogging and being like this is
great about a personal chef is what it's
about
a personal chef it is about a person
what does a personal chef cost what is a
run-of-the-mill not run-of-the-mill what
is a professional chef for Real Cost I
actually know this okay they start
around fifteen hundred dollars a week a
week on top of you have to buy the food
yeah yeah I would assume but how would I
know what food to buy they do it
so there's a flying here that it's
getting on my first and last nerve God
yeah I know I know dude if it's 50 1500
a week
that's what it starts at what do you got
for personal chefs low bro that's what
it starts that's why I said so it starts
at national average is 60 000 a year for
a personal chef they do everything
that's about 15 a week food and
groceries not including groceries though
sure it is oh yeah you're right yeah
okay but here's the thing that's just
someone who prepares your meals and
leaves them at your house or they're
they're there like cooking every meal
yeah
one of our guys here used to be a
personal chef the guy that runs our
whole kitchen thing used to be a
personal chef he didn't tell me but he
did it on Long Island and he told me
like he said before he started working
here he almost became a personal chef
again and he was going to stay on Long
Island because he was I guess in a
relationship or something out there but
I mean he said it was on average the
gigs paid like anywhere from 15 to 2
Grand a week and he lived and he would
live in like their you know they have
like a wing oh so you really mean like
in-house I think you also get free room
and board with it let me ask you a
question you have a house you have we
have the house to you know say we have a
house at enough space to house just one
helper would you have a personal chef uh
a housekeeper or would you have a
personal chef a housekeeper or a
gardener what would you have well
Gardner I mean well the gardener they
come the landscapers come and even if
you have a cleaning service they can
come okay so would you rather have a
personal chef or a housekeeper you could
only have one want someone cooking your
meals or clean your dishes what about
personal I would have a without a doubt
all day personal chef all day really
yeah that will change my entire life you
know what I take over personal chef in a
heartbeat driver
you want a driver
dude are you kidding me you never have
to worry about driving ever again dude
just get an Uber no but dude you got a
guy whose job take you out for the night
he's waiting outside wherever you got to
do that's not oh my God man
can't you just get a car service how
much is it to have a to have your own
personal I bet you'd have a personal
driver is more expensive than having a
chef I bet you it is that's who it is
yeah because now you can't do it price
is against these days you take it up
with Bloom Cafe
very good thank you very good we did a
bit last week about taking Bloom Cafe
which is his vegan cafe on Staten Island
which is awesome we just were yelling
about taking it up but I don't know
that's going to be my presidential
slogan that's really funny I um I don't
care you know
you gotta hire a person that's willing
to do it because the car service like
for a day is like 500 a day yes A day I
do personal checks it's saying it could
be as low as 35 000 a year for a
full-time driver 40 hours a week yeah
that's you saying hey I got the car you
got to drive me everywhere do you want
to be on salary that's not hot I don't
think that's hiring like a service yeah
for 35 Grand they're like listen I drive
you over it but I'm allowed to text
while I do it
dude 40 hours a week that's BR like I
would never need him before 8 pm
pick me up at five is that eight hours
on the clock no no how does that work
you don't know pimp sorry guys why don't
we have I mean dude I mean having a
personal I mean sixty thousand dollars a
lot of money but it's not like like
there's a realm of possibility where
like the average person could afford
that how about this we all become
roommates splitting rent number one so
that we can get a bigger place than
normal and then if we all split rent and
live together we could do like a
chauffeur a chef a train you know what I
mean we could all chip in that that x
amount and then all reap the benefits of
that am I doing the original in the
pilot of the Golden Girls
they had a personal chef
no that was like a thing they all had
together it was a gay character and he
was their personal chef and it was the
arable pilot it was the pilot that aired
and then he never was mentioned ever
again after the first part of the pilot
they cut the character it was
unnecessary it made no sense it was like
these women like struggling in their 50s
or 60s to live the ah
oh you're cramping up he's zooming on
his face on his face as he said these
women struggling in their 50s and 60s he
was like oh dude what what is it is it
your neck no it's my best dehydrated I
know I'm just not drinking enough water
no you that that every time you get a
cramp like that that's water actually I
haven't had any water today well you but
you never drink water I know he only
pees about once a week do you know about
his urination why he pees like three or
four times a week why
which is a very interesting what I feel
like doing well you don't pay once a day
I pee what once a day once a day so
seven times a week on average is when
you pay I I swear to God I'm not like
I've it's
1 30 I've peed five times today really
yeah 100 years I did because I had a
because I did pretzel I had this big ice
cappuccino and so I came in right before
I did my pee for today was that was your
first piece since one uh what's the last
time you peed
I'm not even joking I'm not joking I
peed
probably yesterday morning yesterday
morning which is insane yeah that's nuts
I know it's something's wrong right I
believe that oh yeah well I mean not I
don't know if anything's wrong I believe
it is six to eight times is what was
supposed to say if that's what you
believe that's what you believe I'm not
here to I'm not here to uh kind of tell
you that you can't believe in what you
want to believe in you believe that you
don't pee enough I try to drink water
though a lot and the water doesn't you
know when I drink the most water I swear
to God through the night I put at
minimum a 40 ounce uh bottle near my
bedside and I pretty much get through it
by the time I wake up again you wake up
and drink water no all night long all
night long every I have every I have it
right now every couple weeks I get
dehydrated to the point where I feel
fluish
yeah I'm achy I get like a back pain
whatever I have it right now when's the
last time you took a sip of water
yesterday no I drank I forced the glass
down this morning
I had like a little bit of water
yesterday I barely drank anything you
know that is like legitimately the best
thing you could do for yourself and the
worst thing you could do is not is not
do it yeah I mean but the problem is
just yeah I wasn't brought up like when
you hit dehydration it's too late you
try to drink the water and it tastes
terrible for whatever reason really if
you're not on top of it the closer you
get the dehydration the less you want to
drink the water I'll tell you how much I
drink water okay I'm staying in a hotel
the next couple days for work last night
I got back to the hotel it was midnight
I walked upstairs got to my room and
that there was no there's no room
service there's no uh bar there's no
water in the room and I didn't have any
with me and I was like [ __ ] so I got
dressed again I went downstairs I was
gonna go to walk and find water to buy
to bring upstairs the second I opened
the door it starts pouring rain so I'm
like what am I going to do it's this
little hotel that was one worker only so
I went to I was like I had to get water
somehow and she goes I can go get cups
and she goes we have like at the coffee
machine there's a filter I could just
fill you cups of water I was like please
could you do that and she had like 16
ounce like plastic cups for like coffee
and she filled me six cups of water full
in a tray and I brought it upstairs and
I put six open plastic cups of 16 ounce
water by my bedside and last night I
went through three of them and then
three waiting for today so they go oh
but you know what the thing is though
when you get back to those all the
settlements right in that water you're
going to be drinking toxic water yeah is
it true is that true yeah I was a little
nervous yeah because you
container like that all the dust
particles all that stuff but you know
what listen you gotta drink water you
got to drink water yeah do you um who's
your favorite philosopher do you have a
favorite
uh no no I guess no not not enough I I
like the shack yeah I don't know if it
counts as a philosopher but I like a lot
of the Freud stuff a lot like I find
like his take on like God and all that
stuff very interesting yeah I've been
listening you ever you ever listen to or
know about like Nietzsche yeah a little
bit do you know that his I didn't know
this about him do you know that his
entire like he died like zero people
knew who he was he would sell he would
write these books like he he literally
he first of all he's like a [ __ ] his
whole life and then he would write these
books that would take him 15 years to
write one book like I think it was
whatever 1890 it's not the right year
but like in 1890 he wrote a book that he
was 20 years life work and he sold four
copies in one year
I was listening I said this one year is
most which is it became I think it's
called like I forgot what the name of
the book is but it's now it's a classic
but in his time he sold four books yes
but could you imagine doing things like
that and then he kept going didn't care
at all and he just was like I know that
this is going to mean something one day
that's to know that that's insane yeah
right yeah well I mean he turned it
around when he invented Mad Libs but
other than that I don't know this is
what it is yeah Nietzsche invented Mad
Libs
you know Mad Libs what's Mad Libs oh you
know what Mad Libs is
you know what Mad Lib says you don't
know what mad libs are it's like the
book that you open and it's like give me
an adjective and you fill it in give me
a verb and you fill it in and then you
you read it but with the you've never
heard of Mad Libs no dude it was like
when you got it when you were a kid it
was like they were we haven't
practically this is an Impractical
Jokers Mad Libs actually out there
really yeah so it's a popular thing that
we had when we were kids or it's still
out now and you'll you basically there's
a story it's already pre-written but
every few sentence lines they'll be like
give me a noun and you put the noun in
you don't know what the story is and
then I read the story back to you and
it's like you know it's supposed to be a
real hoot
bro he invented that no no he invented
it the first versions of that I don't
believe that that later became you need
to prove that I could just Google it I
can I can prove it yeah yeah mad li no I
didn't I didn't know that he invented
that I had no idea
oh Ari's here there's no way he invented
that hey he's a Mad Lib
[Music]
what's that sound the sound of Shopify
my folks that's a new sales sound
Shopify is freaking awesome what it does
is it gives entrepreneurs the resources
once reserved for big businesses upstart
startups established businesses alike
can sell everywhere and anywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed I love
how Shopify just makes it so easy for us
to sell stuff and do stuff and it's just
literally just money in the account you
sell the thing it's one two three it's
very very easy and I can reach customers
all over social networks online anywhere
Facebook Tick Tock Pinterest anything
that Shopify covers it all
go to shopify.com hey babe right now all
lowercase okay shopify.com hey babe for
a free 14-day trial and get full access
to shopify's entire Suite of features
grow your business with Shopify today go
to shopify.com hey babe right now that's
shopify.com slash hey babe gain insights
as you grow with detailed reporting of
conversion rates profit margins and
Beyond it is more than a store Shopify
grows with you this is possibility
powered by Shopify shopify.com hey babe
14 free uh free 14-day trial and full
access to shopify's entire Suite of
features go check it out so have you
never seen Mad Libs I've never seen Mad
Libs all right you know what man you
know what mad libs are of course right
absolutely I do there's ours should be
yeah hey come here there's Ari shaffir
with an orange handkerchief on look look
at Ari he's never heard he's never heard
of Mad Libs
he's saying that Nietzsche invented the
first version of Mad Libs you did that's
what he's saying that's ridiculous hey
he's saying he invented the first
version of Mad Libs yeah I was talking
about how Nichi his whole career yeah
nobody knew who he was at all he's one
of his most best-selling books he sold
four copies in one year he did the birth
of tragedy and then he did that one yeah
I think birth of tragedy sold four
copies in one year and then nobody
nobody cared about him and it was his
sister his sister is the one who edited
his sister is the one who after he died
republish his books but his sister was
pro-nazi so everybody thinks Nietzsche
is this pro-nazi sympathizer but he
hated anti-semite I hated that too but
his sister was like no no my brother is
all about the Nazis so his sister's just
a little [ __ ] yeah you're lying about
the Nietzsche thing this is like when
you pretend it like I don't know what
diet coke was it's like what this is
like when you did the thing where you
pretended you didn't know what diet coke
was he didn't you try to sell him but
you didn't know what diet coke no not to
not me so you did it to somebody you've
told me I convinced the honest I didn't
know it Coke Zero but Diet Coke I
convinced them by the way
I'm lying yeah that's a minute yeah look
at this phone look at this text I sent
Ari last night all right shaffir's on
the Pod everyone
come out what how did this happen I'm
Aria we've known each other for a while
uh we've become friends over the years I
didn't know you were coming here today
this is great I'm gonna meet somebody
here
Lucky Charms we also saw Ari's taping of
his special last night okay yes can we
say yeah sure it's titled Jew yeah and I
saw it and it was legit I mean
legitimately
unbelievable yeah I mean really I use
the word inspiring after I saw it it was
a wonderful piece of work that's nice
yeah so it looked amazing that the
material was fantastic but I said this
to him I get out of the Uber after a
beautiful night with friends yeah I sent
him a message I write him this text I'm
literally welled up a little bit as I
was typing it all right congrats again
on a terrific job with your special man
I'm really proud of you buddy you should
be thrilled with this excellent
excellent work no response
you think I'm on my text after that I'm
hanging out with friends how about today
hey I still haven't gone I woke up
hungover congrats again I'm not just
saying it that was really [ __ ] great
be very proud no response literally woke
up with my head on my dog bed he was on
the couch you got that drunk yeah I was
I was like what the [ __ ] how did Phil
getting drunk for the first time in like
four months six weeks no alcohol six
weeks how'd it feel felt great I got a
Collide at 25. we cracked it up with all
the comics there it was awesome it was
awesome but a little tuned up I wrote I
wrote crush it tonight man I'll be there
and then I did inshallah
that's that's what I did Chris Chris is
the worst yeah I don't know if everybody
knows this yeah Chris is the I've never
met somebody to make chocolate plans
yeah that you can't rely on like
literally yeah you can't it's at least
13 consecutive times now with you where
you've called me it was your idea you
say tomorrow we'll definitely hang out
yeah I'll meet you at this place it
comes
here's the thing I know I know that this
is uh it's just it's a horrible uh
characteristic personality
characteristic but the reason why I do
this because what happens is you have
the best of intentions it's hours before
we're supposed to make a plan I get
crippling social anxiety about it and my
brain then says you can't do that you
got to do something else remember I was
talking about shadowing Carl Jung
shadowing I gotta figure out what the
shadow is inside why I do that I gotta
figure it out by the way crippling
social anxiety means someone better
called No I know exactly yeah exactly
birds in town yeah yeah I didn't wanted
to do a vlog
yeah
whenever I make plans with Comics now
I'm like putting your calendar and
they're like okay I'm like no no let me
see you put it in your account people
accountable yeah all the time with it
yeah yeah holding people accountable
there's a study like when you hold
people accountable even if somebody like
me who's a Frosted Flakes
that goes nah you're great no it goes up
your your success rate goes through the
roof like like if you if you're like oh
if you're like uh if you just have your
blinker on there's this study if you
can emerge Lanes
almost like nobody nobody lets you in
but if you put your arm out yeah and say
let me through everybody lets you in and
nobody even gets mad at you same thing
with the aggressive be aggressive 9-1-1
like if somebody died I had a heart
attack right now nobody calls him nobody
calls unless you unless I go Sal call
9-1-1 having a heart attack but call
9-1-1 wow like you have to point out
somebody say accountability do it if you
ask Joe about 9 to be like how many
minutes do I have left I know yeah
you're gonna hit me with that you're
about to hit me with that and I beat you
wait what I don't understand you're
cheap I'm cheap oh oh I have a minutes
phone yeah
I think you've been on stage I
understand uh everybody one of the
greatest place coming out on YouTube one
of the greatest flakes I ever we don't
know yet oh you don't know maybe it's
coming out somewhere else one of the
greatest flakes anybody's ever done is
Ari we were we were down the shore
together sure I got a text
we're down at Montauk I got a text
somebody was saying you want to do this
podcast and it's like do you want to do
this with me it's like yeah definitely
can I go okay I'm confirming us both and
he's like okay cool I was like it's a
week for Monday I'm confirming it's
about to be like okay cool I put it in
my lock it in they're texting me all day
they're like the day of they're like uh
are you and already good I'm like I'm
good he's not responding I finally get
in touch with him I go dude we gotta go
he's like I took a bunch of mushrooms I
forgot it's like you I don't remember
that but I believe you
that's what you did instead he's a good
example of a guy that just goes with the
flow like I don't think I mean guilt is
a normal human emotion but you don't
like you want your day wasn't ruined
because you made a mistake no it's like
I'll try to be better next time that's
it that's all it is and that's I I know
I feel like I feel like listening I
don't know why dude I feel like all I've
been doing lately is instead of blasting
you know 103.5 KTU just you know [ __ ]
uh um uh old school like uh techno music
style freestyle I've been listening to
all these philosophers on YouTube and I
I'm probably mitchie's mad libs
Nietzsche's Mad Libs yeah Carl's junk yo
bro Carl Jung I mean that guy was I
wonder how many times the sentence
started off yo bro call y'all
I mean you're going Rogan on us over
here is it too much you're getting
you're hitting bro in philosophy
no he's just he was he's all about
exploring people's uh dark sides he
invented color forms he did invent
colors yes the shrinky dinks also what's
your thing
what do you mean darksides
I don't know Ryan sickler I brought it
up I to be honest with you I brought it
up because I thought somebody was going
to jump in with a good philosophy story
and then nobody did it so I'm kind of
just stopping philosophy is my favorite
class in college was it yeah I loved it
philosophy chicks are easy to [ __ ] they
are yeah they like to do it they're like
this is about me and exploring my
insights and you're like I'll help you
explain yeah yeah I'd like to come in
your insides yeah oh my God yes I put
off your pancreas lady what what are you
guys arguing about today what what do
you guys arguing about you're on hey
babe
we are gonna do um but later Sal and I
one of the UPS we're recording is BLT
versus bacon egg and cheese that's gonna
be making lettuce tomatoes
I don't think so some of the polls that
you guys put up it like they're not
making lettuce tomato is one of the
worst sandwiches
our sandwich that's a good sandwich
though BLT can beat a bacon egg and
cheese Joe it was invented in the Great
Depression when they I can't anything
on this
you do this to yourself can you tell me
you tell me I take you tell me I take
you tell me I take the favorites but
it's not true you just you tell me that
after I beat you by a landslide but
beforehand you think you're gonna win I
I can't believe a bacon egg and cheese
is gonna Landslide yeah well bacon no
Bacon's a wash right and then egg versus
lettuce
and tomato versus cheese shut up don't
even do the episodes
[Laughter]
yeah trading Trading Places when uh when
one of the Duke Brothers is talking to
he's like patronizing uh patronizing uh
Eddie Murphy and he's like he's like
Billy this is uh bacon he's trying to
teach her about Commodities and stuff
when the tree and he goes this is bacon
which you could find on a bacon lettuce
and tomato sandwich and then anywhere we
just breaks the fourth wall and just
looks at the camera like that yeah
it's so great that movie is a
masterpiece have you guys seen that um
George Carlin documentary not yet One
HBO Max did you see it uh-uh dude dude
you got to stop talking about philosophy
it's not philosophy
he's probably my favorite philosopher
yeah that's what I was going to say but
I didn't know if that counted I was
going to say you have a tattoo right
yeah I I absolutely I do have George
Carlin he has a lot of tattoos though so
I'm not that special you have like a
ladder on your arm too maybe you didn't
have like a ladder I thought you had a
ladder no we by the way we're still
supposed to get our tattoos we never got
them what are we supposed to get I was
gonna get the hoagie and you were gonna
get the Verrazano Bridge we're gonna pay
for the other guy to get it we swore on
the podcast
dude and I gotta get that tattoo I saw
here's your shoulder blades no no the
Arizona yeah with constant repairs going
on no we're like yeah that yeah we're
tattooing and different with the Easy
Pass
little people jumping off it no do you
know it's a classic New York just Guido
[ __ ] tattoo is Jesus Christ just
Jesus Christ with his hands out with
each twin tower going through each hole
in his hand oh no I've seen that tattoo
a million times no it's like never
forget any VA forget oh my God
oh yeah dude you see that you go to Bay
Ridge or Staten Island you'll see that
all all over you know what I can picture
you with you don't do you have it you
don't have a tattoo right I have three
tattoos
what am I saying what I could picture
you with though is uh the rosary like
it's around your neck for real oh yeah
how a woman would get her makeup
tattooed on her face I get the rosary
yeah and it's like kind of like you know
like barbed wire but but rosaries yeah
yeah yeah there it is or what I'd like
or what I'd get that on one arm and then
on the left arm I'd get Jesus's Crown of
Thorns with blood dripping down my face
yeah yeah don't you have like the
Commandments or something on you oh yes
tablets oh you got something like that I
have a cross on my back with the word
faith written at the bottom of it which
I didn't know oh my God I didn't ask for
the word faith what the [ __ ] is that I
got it on two from my friend's brother
who's a tattoo on us and he did it at
like one o'clock in the morning and uh I
said you know I wanted to cross with the
rosary beads and he gave me that and
then at the bottom when he showed it me
in the mirror he was like it looks good
right I was like yeah but what's the
word on the bottom he goes Faith oh you
told me he did it on his own yeah he
just added
yo cancer or he thought that I said
Faith or something like that so some
there's the word faith is on my back
without me asking for it oh my God how
funny is that oh my God Jesus you should
get that you should get the nine
Commandments and take out honor thy
father and mother because your parents
are abandoned you yeah truthfully
yeah yeah
our neighbor's wife I might actually get
a tattoo of a pig this week
I just thought of it I serious
last night I actually learned a lot
about religion from you you had a bit on
Moses
when you were like
it was so funny with the they picked him
up in the [ __ ] River but they still
knew his name is still Moses uh I don't
know I got lucky guess
when is it gonna come out I'm hoping for
another month of editing then color
stuff I'm not the six six to eight weeks
of finishing it and then like and then
figuring out where it goes what happens
in those six to eight weeks of coloring
okay
four to six weeks is editing my editor
is going to Disneyland so we got to
start in a week
I don't know the California one the one
the one where Mickey Mouse died I'm
telling you that I don't think it should
take 20 to 30 business days to edit a
special yeah I think maybe two weeks at
the most edit that thing
are you paying by the week in Japan okay
dude that should not take four weeks
sorry you're gonna you're gonna break I
did my last time in four weeks and
everybody comes like that's incredibly
fast we've never had one done that first
they're lying to you they lie in a week
and a half what I swear to God we put
mine out in a week and a half yeah but I
saw his editing notes it was a [ __ ]
dart board and he was just throwing [ __ ]
at it we left all we left everything in
yeah
I gotta drink some water
start a podcast called philosophy hyenas
I should babes you know what I love you
love door down oh I love your dash I use
it this weekend doordash is awesome let
me tell you something about doordash
whatever you want to eat tonight door
Dash has got it maybe you want a
home-cooked favorite but you don't feel
like going to the store well guess what
doordash or maybe you want something
exciting and new but it would be great
to stay in tonight doordash guess who
connects you with everything you want
whenever and however you want it
along with the restaurants you love now
you can guess what else oh but you know
what you know what Sal you know what the
only thing I don't like about doordash
you can't get groceries on it yes you
can now you can yes you can you can get
a host of things on doordash you
download the app any neighborhood I was
on the road this weekend in Syracuse
nice the place that hotel did not have
any room service okay I was hungry for
lunch right and I looked on doordash and
I got every single freaking restaurant
in the within 20 miles and I got it
delivered right to my hotel room door
literally last week my daughter wanted
to cut her own hair yeah and I wanted to
let her do it because we were having Dad
time and I didn't have scissors doordash
delivered scissors to the house cut my
daughter's hair now I'm sleeping in the
room no doordash is making family
memories that's what now at the Ramada
they they don't have room service use
doordash do we store this full circle
full circle with 300 000 Partners which
is you know which is about three hundred
thousand a hundred people I've had in my
life too yes yeah yeah 300 000 sexual
partners you could support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite National restaurants like
Popeyes Chipotle and cheesecake they
need your help they need your help and
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 biente Cinco off and zero delivery
fees on the first order of 15 or more
when you download the doordash app and
enter the code hey babe hey babe that's
25 off up to ten dollar value and zero
deliver delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter the code hey
babe don't forget that's code hey babe
for 25 off your first order with Georgia
subject to change terms Supply what's up
baby you know we love magic spoon here
and hey babe it is an awesome serial
zero grams of sugar 13 14 grams of
protein and only four net carbs in each
serving 140 calories a serving so it is
healthy wealthy it's keto friendly it's
gluten-free it's grain free it's soy
free and it's low carb I mean they have
the best flavors too peanut butter
cookies and cream Maple waffle blueberry
muffin yes cinnamon roll and Honey Nut I
love it and even more exciting magic
spoon just brought back their cereal
bars well I didn't know this they got
their cereal bars back they were so
popular that they brought them back
permanently it is the perfect convenient
on the go companion for cereal I get me
the cereal bars I love that and right
now you're going to get a great discount
all you got to do is go to
magicspoon.com hey babe and do hey babe
at checkout you can get five dollars off
your order that is magicspoon.com hey
babe use the code hey babe save five
dollars off your order get those cereal
bars wow but
it's just got dude it's Gotta but he's
just got boots he's not bad you're not
Joey Boots Joey Boots oh Joey Boots
no dude I'm telling you if you get when
we want to get ripped we're getting
ripped for other guys because women
don't care at all what our bodies look
like Amen to that at all they really
don't they genuinely couldn't care less
as a matter of fact I think the more
shout out women shout out women shout
out shout out uh uh women and biological
men that became women shout out
everybody shout out everybody I love it
man shout out being biological yeah
um uh I know we don't have a TV I wish I
finished licking the air in here because
it was so Rife with [ __ ] mistakes
yeah why did a sandwich because he said
he said the sandwich shop is closed
today I'm like I bet it's your shot it's
your [ __ ] get back there and make me a
damn sandwich Serato because you say it
is yeah that's what it is that not right
what's Serato yeah that's closed
what language closed in Spanish
oh no you speak relatively good Spanish
it's not bad what are you watching in
Kanto and now I should watch it more
so where's gonna be here every time Ari
does it special he takes a big
sabbatical where's he Where Are You
Gonna where you're gonna uh go I don't
know I want to go to [ __ ] I I'm gonna
go to Paris for a week to the right have
you been for the writing class no never
been and then from there I don't know I
might go from there to somewhere what do
you mean for the writing class I'm
taking a writing class roof path is a
writing class go to Amsterdam wait
what'd you just say taking a writing
class who what did you say before that
both parts is a travel writer it's a
friend of mine he's a writing class in
Paris at the Paris University so you're
gonna go for a week to a class and then
do homework and [ __ ] just to write what
what context of writing short stories
for me oh that's nice yeah
really yeah and then he doesn't like
this kid love someone
uh
it's coming up this summer
I want to go um yeah can I go because
I've actually had some short stories
published I'm not kidding I would like
to take
I'll ask about it is it like a closed
off thing I don't know I can ask him
wait why is it funny that I've had
stories it's just a funny thing to say
yeah short stories published it's very
weird not like I'd like to take this
class like I've done no because because
are you going to the next game I
actually played on my high school team
no no because I didn't want it to sound
like I was just saying I want to
piggyback on your idea it sounds worse
than you said you have short stories
you're doing that and and balling yeah
I'll talk about it when I'm gonna be
exactly where I'm going to be after the
podcast but have you been to Paris no
never so it's rough because you're gonna
go to Paris but then have work to do all
week you're not going to see Power part
of his work is walk around experience
[ __ ] oh all right now really like just
kind of let it hit you yeah he has this
idea called the flour it's his old idea
where you walk you follow a color around
the city you pick a color like red like
go out see the first thing red go find
it and then go the next red to go find
it other people
[Laughter]
yeah it kind of lets it flop yeah I
might try to go to the beach and but are
you supposed to glean a short story out
of that trap
did you just drink it all no
no dude
I think you're drank it on the way back
I think you drank it when I was looking
down that's not true wow yes
you got me God oh sorry about it sorry
yeah
I'm so sorry
Jesus no I well she didn't yep so I
guess it wasn't that hard I just put my
foot down that's a good that's a good
indicator God damn it so now you gotta
go get more water look at this
who's on your shirt
yeah who's that who's that stretched out
man in your shirt
schooly D yeah well Pioneer Pioneer
Pioneer here all right go dude uh
they're shooting they're shooting a TV
show by my house today what TV show Mr
and Mrs Smith
[Laughter]
Mike that's great off Mike yeah we're
all the dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] live
nice I gotta run the second run out it
was better that's a better show
what is Mr and Mr Smith like the movie
the movie but the TV show guess which
[ __ ] dumb sellouts doing a TV show
based on a movie oh let me guess can you
give hints uh yeah he's better than that
I'm not saying he's a dumb sellout I
don't know who it is never thought he
was why would anyone do a [ __ ] TV
show okay so he's better than that
that's one clue way better than that but
don't give it away but give a good who
created the show nothing to do with it
think darker than the original
that's that's a big the original with
Angelina Jolie and Brown Chris Angel no
well you're saying who's the lead or who
who's Mr Smith and Mrs I don't know okay
okay well let me okay let me guess it's
20 22. okay so I would imagine that the
lead which is supposed to be man will
not be played by a man it's supposed to
be white guy will not be played by a
white guy so I would say false true yeah
um I would say the lead of that is um
the lead of of Mr Smith is 20 Questions
yes or no
let's do it okay okay is he a comedian
oh telling which means maybe he thinks
he's a oh I think he's a comic but he's
not well that's tough for us to talk
Dave Coulier no you're gonna go with
that as you're us no no no I'm gonna say
this because
Izzy a comedian maybe he's not primarily
known as a comedy let's let's fill in
granny Joe
um 20 Questions we're finding out 20
Questions yes or no uh you find out who
is playing the new Mr Smith in the new
Mr Smith Smith's
um uh TV show what station is it on I
don't know okay that's not a yes or no
also [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] kidney dumb
thing but you know who you know the
answer I do know the answer no well let
me Eric Andre let me ask you a question
yeah why would we play the game if he
didn't know the answer do you know I
didn't know if he was saying let's all
try to guess who's playing the part can
you drink we have to ask him 20
Questions no no I I didn't know we were
asking Ari specifically so do we do we
ask any yet is he a comedian no is he
Dave Coulier no yeah that's a bit yeah
is he is he a known actor yes okay
is he living or dead no
I'm gonna I'm gonna already
guessing you're gonna waste the question
do you how many questions are we up to
four four is he black we yes no you just
said is he not white okay okay yeah is
he black yeah yeah all right okay all
right
um is he a movie star yes
I already know who it is
that's impossible
um guarantee it's Michael B Anthony
I was gonna guess Michael B Jordan or
Michael B Jordan I mean the guy from the
guy from Creed Michael B Jordan
[ __ ]
Idris Elba maybe but I'm not gonna say
it
um all right you want to narrow it down
is he American yes
my next guest was gonna be non-american
what movie was he in that's not a yes or
no oh okay is he handsome
I mean that's subjective that's crazy oh
yeah
was he in comic book movies
like superhero movies
I don't know his whole repertoire I
can't answer that question okay okay
okay
okay
an Oscar
I I doubt that very much hold on I can
look that up was he also on any other
television shows ever
as a primary character yes okay it's a
movie star who's also been a primary
character on television show this is the
lead of Mr and Mrs Smith
I got it I know who it is John Amos Don
Cheadle no oh good guess bro I cannot
narrow it down once you have that narrow
it down yeah yeah yeah we're [ __ ] up
big time here [ __ ] cool yeah all
right all right um is he is he um very
physically fit
he's got to be uh it's Mr Smith yeah I
mean he's got to be for this
okay is he known for comedy roles
not necessarily not necessarily okay I
know who it is yeah Kevin Hart
no
that's a garbage you keep guessing wait
it's Anthony Anderson no what are you
guys we cannot just keep naming black
attractors we have to narrow it down
it's Oprah Winfrey all right all right
all right
did we say he's black they're just not
white black not white and black was his
last movie a big hit
this last movie you gotta let me look at
this whole [ __ ] weapon I'm just I'm
trying to ask a decent question here
hold on oh yeah your best subjective
question big hold on I mean Ari started
off by saying he's way he's better than
this for doing it he can't believe he's
doing this it's got to be Denzel
Washington
yeah
no it can't be done so Denzel's too old
he's gonna be a guy like in his like
late 20s early 30s at the most I have
the answer he has not won a Grammy I
mean an Oscar that's right that wasn't
my question you said did you win an
Oscar no no he said that earlier I said
was his last movie A Smash Hit or a hit
I'm answering his last question not an
Oscar winner I didn't ask you to ask her
a question Sal did I believe that too I
didn't ask that yes you did I don't
think I did
um
you yeah you did
okay well I didn't maybe Chris did oh uh
does he have a famous wife oh
thank you if you don't know
I mean I don't keep up with these guys
like who yeah hold on I'll go look that
up he was also in a television show so
think of like really good television
shows
is it um is it Donald Glover it is
Donald Glover wow yes no no
yeah there it is he's Mr Smith crazy
right what are you doing yeah wow you're
[ __ ] childish Gambino is the greatest
thing in the world
bigger than doing that he's what I don't
think he's bigger
mainstream though mainstream who's um
who's the Mrs Smith then
um do we know yeah Adrian appellucci oh
yeah you you just guessed Alan Glover
you guessed what you said because I
thought of a hit TV show who's here who
was here
the FedEx guy oh get them on yeah
I mean the new Mr Smith
have you have you watched Atlanta oh
it's great so good I haven't seen three
yet though he won an award for that oh
yeah never Oscar because you said you
know what gave it away is when he said
he didn't win a Grammy I was like ah
he's a musician too
yeah
let's talk about more philosophy stuff
oh yeah
he's not a comedian now why Joe but he
starts
he has a stand-up special
so what the capacola is a little late
you think that's bigger than Beyond hey
babe no my back is killing me man it's
true it's the water gun I'm trying man
I'm trying you think you're gonna drink
a cup of water in that painting box and
go away like that oh no but I just feel
terrible don't do that to me I didn't do
it to him by the way did you right in
front of all your faces
do it again
take two uh I mean I don't know why you
would give it to the main guys and not
the guests why are they blue again I
don't sign your checks
but I just gave you ecstasy
[Laughter]
Ari don't you do that yeah it was a good
day I already do
uh a leaves you only need two I'll leave
you're actually supposed to take one but
I just thought you should take two
he's trying to say that he slept wrong
and that's why his back hurts but he
told me what his weekend was like
hey how come our kill Tony episode
hasn't come out yet you think they're
shelf in it they haven't come out yet to
help me promote that special yeah it's
not the week before not out because I
guess one of us got canceled yeah award
maybe it came out and it did so bad that
not even know maybe maybe because I
haven't heard a goddamn thing about one
thing not one thing dude interesting one
I think it was his best one of all time
it was fun I remember it being fun it
was fun I got I kept getting drunker and
drunker and drunker and then it had fun
but it was one of those things did you
have any good any good uh performances
or were they like anything yeah uh yeah
uh what's his name that Asian kid was
great Hans Kim is a great comment that
chick that looked like a potato she was
good that was her joke that was a joke
then the guy with ALS was pretty good
too guy that was tough to understand the
guy with ALS is [ __ ] his body feels
better than derosa's right now
how does ALS manifest what happens so
ALS a myotropic lateral sclerosis
so you know polio is a lower motor
neuron disease ALS upper and lower this
is the thing we dump ice on ourselves
for yeah so yeah that made it go away
it's an ice bucket challenge you know
what it is you know what actually
[ __ ] it is and this is it's like
scary when you like start to learn about
this stuff and I've worked with a lot of
patients that had it when I was a
physical therapist like it can happen to
anyone nobody knows what happens but
basically nobody knows how you get it
but basically you have these things
around your cells called the myelin
sheaths so myelin sheets is like the car
like my brain is saying move my hand
like that because my the impulses are
going on my myelin sheath which isn't
like cars driving from nerve neuron to
neuron and going it's like a highway
right and then with ALS dude with ALS
the myelin she starts to disintegrate
and then you got no car so now the
impulses that say my head my brain is
telling my neuron hey go move go move
his finger and the brain's saying yeah
but I got no car the neuron is saying a
loss of motor skills because the
deterioration of the myelin sheath is
that what happens with Lyme disease when
you like brush your teeth and you're
like I won't go no lime because I don't
actually I don't know I don't know what
what Lyme disease I just know you get it
from ticks I know if you get a bite on
your body and it's such a dummy it's
such a brilliant person at the same time
yeah so it's called being in the closet
oh I also don't think there's ever a
sentence that was like and then dude you
know what happens to your myelin sheaths
dude yeah I want to always do a show or
YouTube series like that where I try to
explain the things I learned in physical
therapy school but in that oh that's
right in that tone you know yeah no you
should explain you should explain stuff
like that to just like a whole group of
like guidos babe you want to know what's
[ __ ] about some history thing you
want to know what's wild about you know
Gettysburg yeah but ALS it's uh it's an
interesting it's interesting and now the
uh prevalence of it is going up for some
weird reason and people don't know why
we don't know why because still to this
day in 2022 2022 if you got a [ __ ]
pneumonia if you caught pneumonia you
could still die I'd still die today
Bernie Mac right now
I got hospitalized for pneumonia yeah
but any dude anybody it can happen you
know someone really famous died of
pneumonia recently no pneumonia
is that what killed Ralphie May or was
it was fluid the perfect health up until
then yeah I just mean like yeah but like
that's one of those emotions also one of
those last things
about at that store my dad went in the
hospital for pneumonia a few years ago
and I was like do I need I was in LA at
the time and I was like do I need to fly
home yeah and my friend's wife was a
nurse she was like if they put a
breathing tube it you better get on a
plane yeah are you serious well that's
that's what started killing everyone in
the beginning with covet if you got
covered earlier early in like the first
three months everyone started the
doctors just didn't know what what else
to do they would say oh pneumonia let me
put them on same as uh HIV pneumonia was
the big they just said but they were
making you worse now they wouldn't do
that they wouldn't put you on a
ventilator there's no intubated
intubating anymore not I mean I think at
the very very very last stages but they
were quick doctors didn't know they were
pulling yeah trigger quick that's yeah
yeah hey you want to see my dog's
favorite trick okay trick start crying
just start crying but keep it going uh
I'm a little sad I it sucks
I don't have a mile in cheese oh my God
look at this acting they gave him a
sitcom yeah
exactly and because of my acting that
[ __ ] comes on my YouTube it's not even
on CBS
like
maybe it's only sympathetic to Jews
not Germans
there it is you can't do sitcom acting
he's gotta do movie acting commercial
acting commercial yeah yeah she's so
awesome she isn't awesome though I just
you know what's interesting though
because I love I love this dog it's
beautiful dog but you know people like I
don't want kids I mean Ari literally
snipped himself I don't want a pet you
don't want a pet I would never I'd
rather have 10 kids than one pet really
isn't that wild I don't like zero Parts
you ever have one yes two you've had two
oh yeah
hi Larry and then my Dalmatian Cruella
which ate um which ate all the uh the
Clorox in the basement when I was like
10 but I just don't to me the idea of
having to deal with a pet is is
exhausting but yet I have three kids I
feel the same way about kids see it's
interesting isn't it interesting thing
you had the kid that ate all the Clorox
yeah I would I had one of those that's
why I got the snipped eventually I was
like I can't be responsible with this
I've lost two already did you find
uh any depression after you got the
vasectomy there's a big study about
depression and vasectomies well one
thing that makes depression go away is
blasting loads inside [ __ ] random
chicks yeah yeah kids remember that if
your kids are feeling depressed out
there remember all you got to do is
blast loads inside random chicks true
that's all you got to do well you got to
get the vasectomy first oh yeah well or
b12.
that's God's facility I think we're
gonna pull the cat trigger I think I'm
gonna finally get a cat oh
you you're buying a house you're getting
a cat what's going on with you if you
want if you want your house to smell
like [ __ ] all the time cat's the way to
go oh oh oh look at me I'm already
I make jokes about cats leave my cat
alone dude look at you why do you think
it's gonna smell like [ __ ] because they
[ __ ] in the house because I'm going but
I'm gonna get one of those uh
self-cleaning litter boxes with the
scent okay you'll be the one
my house smells like Puerto Ricans you
don't think there's a way to have it
because they [ __ ] in the house they [ __ ]
in the house yeah um outside cat dude
your cat you're gonna take your cat to
the Poconos and get eaten by a mountain
lion
he posted a video sweater Christ like
two weeks ago he posted the video of his
dog getting attacked by an alligator on
Instagram and freaked everybody yeah
exactly like Bandit exactly you can post
it identical and also I started getting
texts like dude what happened up here
man what happened and it was identical
on the dock and an alligator come out
and grabbed them and yank them into the
water and killed him or did not kill him
dog got away swung to safety wow but we
thought it was Bandit I had alligator
meat for the first time last week did
you it was good it's an Alligator Soul
in Savannah Georgia it was good did you
eat out go to Alligator salt how is that
how is Savannah dude Savannah told you
about it right Savannah was awesome I
love that City so much where I was like
yeah to the historical district oh my
God
I went to every everything every um
square square yeah every Square I went
to and you know what they made the
squares I learned yes because to defend
the city yes yes the defense they could
get all the soldiers out and then their
backs everybody's you know would have
their guns towards Invader in any
direction you show up to Savannah you
don't know the blueprint you get that
wrecked wrecked on yeah you're done the
only thing they did [ __ ] up on and this
is the same thing that the New York
[ __ ] up on is they the cities I mean
immediately immediately the British when
they were taking it's as well the
Revolutionary War started the British
I'm talking about in 15 minutes took
over the entire city of New York and the
entire city of Savannah immediately
because they set up our we set up our
Colonial defenses our cannons couldn't
reach their ships but their cannons were
destroying our cities from the middle of
the water so they were shooting cannons
that would just land in the water we
killed all the fish and then within 20
minutes both cities were like realize we
[ __ ] up the Cannons don't reach the
ships Wow Let's just give them the city
immediately
so Savannah was taken like that and New
York taken like that the only ones that
weren't were Philly in Boston would they
they put up good fight how we got uh
Beijing we just put our warships right
at the edge of Beijing and we're like
take our opium we were [ __ ] we don't
have babies oh uh England
what do you mean they were like they
just put their warships right into
Beijing like you gotta do trade with us
yeah and although we're just gonna keep
the bomb the [ __ ] out of you that's what
it is yeah and they're like I guess
we're doing opium trade I guess we're
gonna do it yeah I'm reading this book
about
um Manhattan million I ain't sweating
you're not though about it's called the
island of the center of the world and
it's about
um Manhattan with the Dutch before the
British got here do you know like in
1640
in Manhattan gay homosexuality accepted
free slaves uh Native American tribes
intermingling with each other there's
something about New York City I was like
Benetton yeah dude it's United College
of Benetton 1640. yeah there was just a
very like Liberal Liberal place and then
and then the Dutch because the Dude the
Dutch the Dutch they've been about
anything goes the Dutch have said from
the finishing listen to this every week
I mean this is brutal dude who gives a
[ __ ]
people like it it's nuts I would like to
enjoy look at everyone on their phones
they're Googling I'm trying to find
themselves into it that's why everyone's
on their phones are smelling like a cat
by the way what what is that that's how
you stop your house from smelling like a
cat oh from wacktopia the place that
sells stuff that makes you that that has
a vested interest in business-wise I can
hate you I mean it's like clear it's
wrong
I am supportive I'm telling you hey
don't make this mistake I need a pet
though what you know what you know
what's so funny he's like you this is
[ __ ] we gotta listen to this and then
this contribution is oh yeah yeah
instead he wants to talk about
self-cleaning cat litter oh my God Joe
go ahead either you're in or out with
comedy yeah which one is it dude if you
have the sandwich shop what are you
talking about you remember you're
talking about Carl Young in the history
in Manhattan yeah but I'm gonna do a
[ __ ] special I call Young I don't
want to let that drop I want to know
where you're going with this you know
what you guys want to know if you guys
want to know about what I have to say
about Carl Young and Island Manhattan
you could see it on the next episode
this has been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe